let's take a look at word-based
tokenization
word-based tokenization is the idea of
splitting the raw text into words
by splitting on spaces or other specific
rules
punctuation in this algorithm
each word has a specific number or id
attributed to it
here let's has the id 250 do has 861
and tokenization followed by an
exclamation mark has 345.
this approach is interesting as the
model has representations
that are based on entire words
the information held in a single number
is high
as a word contains a lot of contextual
and semantic
information
however this approach does have its
limits
for example the word dog and the word
dogs are very similar
and their meaning is close the word
based tokenization
however will attribute entirely
different ids to these two words
and the model will therefore learn two
different embeddings for these two words
this is unfortunate as you would like
the model to understand that these words
are indeed related
and that dogs is simply the plural form
of the word dog
another issue with this approach is that
there are a lot of different words in a
language
if we want our model to understand all
possible sentences in that language
then we will need to have an id for each
different word
and the total number of words which is
also known as the vocabulary size can
quickly become very large
this is an issue because each id is
mapped to a large vector that represents
the word's meaning
and keeping track of these mappings
requires an enormous number of
weights when the vocabulary size is very
large
if we want our models to stay lean we
can opt for our tokenizer
to ignore certain words that we don't
necessarily need
for example here when training our
tokenizer in a text
we might want to take only the 10 000
most frequent words in that text
rather than taking all words from that
text or all languages
words to create our basic vocabulary
the tokenizer will know how to convert
those ten thousand words into numbers
but any other word will be converted to
the out of vocabulary word
or like shown here the unknown word
unfortunately this is a compromise the
model will have the exact same
representation
for all words that it doesn't know which
can result in a lot
of lost information if many unknown
words are present
you